many of those caps possessions here to
start the fourth James drives down a
lane running shot banks and it's good
Curry's got Tristan Thompson on him
curry crossover three-pointer Xcode step
from way downtown and we'll tie it again
how about this Steph Curry
Tristan Thompson that's good defense but
late on the contest curry gets to his
spot bigger dollar Thompson fakes
Thompson fires
a two-pointer for klay Thompson they'll
review it curry with Jefferson leaning
on them curry drives scoop layup misses
Green on the follow five to shoot the
Seelye again goes back up on him game
steps back for three hops ahead LeBron
James from downtown 26 for James
Thompson gets way from Smith drives
left-handed off the glass
hurry now picks them up five to shoot
James powers drives an elaine missed it
[ __ ] Nala contestant Irving drives hop
step inside pulls up misses rebound
taken by Iguodala
they go down low to curry back there go
down low up the lamp
Oh block like James LeBron James with
the rejection great pass by curry
running hard by Iguodala and superhuman
defensive recovery by LeBron James on a
minute remaining and they're putting
Korean the pick-and-roll trying to get
him on Earth
[Applause]
Irving and curry one on one Irving puts
it up let's go Kyrie Irving trip
downtown then the Cavaliers by three
came out of the timeout set to get Steph
Curry on Kyrie Irving they get exactly
what they want everybody out of my way
it's time to dance get some one-on-one
lulls in the sleep forces a late contest
that's a big-time offensive play by
Kyrie Irving but it's a play he's made
his entire life the ability to score and
flat out get it done on the offensive
end
[Applause]